the dude you're looking at here runs a
one-man business developing Chrome
plugins that makes over 20 million
dollars a year that's four times more
than the average NFL quarterback man
it's unfair it's my quarterback one of
the best things about learning to code
is that it gives you the ability to
build money printing machines that
regular people can't in my world the
ultimate freedom in life is to be a
solopreneur with a business that runs
itself on autopilot no deadlines no
bosses no Bugattis Just Pure Freedom but
that's easier said than done you won't
get there with a four hour work week and
for most of us it takes a lot of hard
work and some luck I've built a ton of
side hustles over the years and almost
all of them have failed miserably but a
few of them have been moderately
successful and that's given me enough
wealth to move out of my mom's basement
in today's video I'm going to show you
exactly how I built and deployed my own
real AI software as a service
application with only two days of
programming work but first we need to
talk about the mindset of a side Hustler
Danny postma recently created a project
called headshot Pro that now has over 12
000 customers a lot of people might just
say he got lucky by jumping on the
recent AI hype train and those people
would be absolutely right but the thing
is he made his own luck he first
developed the skills to build things
then identify the problem of corporate
photos being a huge waste of money then
finally when AI got good enough to
replace photographers he was able to
seize the moment here's another anecdote
movie director Quentin Tarantino wrote a
screenplay where Salma Hayek pours
tequila down her leg then some guy
drinks it off of her toes then guess who
he casts in that role
himself that's what making your own luck
is all about the problem is that most of
us won't get this lucky very often and
that's why you need to be prepared to
fail early fail often but always fail
forward the only person that can
actually tell you whether or not you're
going to fail is the customer and that
means you want to try to get real users
giving you feedback as soon as possible
the last thing you want to do is spend
two years building a project in secret
only to release it and find out nobody
actually wants it now that you're in the
right mindset it's time to come up with
an idea of something to build the other
day I came across this trending new
manosphere channel telling men how to
live the Giga Chad lifestyle but weirdly
I was the one narrating it for the body
make sure you exercise so that you can
keep your mental and physical health in
check and I don't ever recall doing that
that's because it's illegally using my
clone voice I'm not the one behind this
Channel and I could tell the FBI to find
this guy and put him in jail but I
actually like the idea of people
replicating my voice for Mass
distribution I like big bundles and I
cannot lie a few other JS devs can't
deny that when a site blows in so little
Firebase 3DS interface you get sprung
and that's how I can came up with the
idea for vocalize.cloud a platform that
allows you to use my voice legally and
not just my voice but all kinds of
different celebrities so far I've
reached out to Morgan Freeman Tom Cruise
Scarlett Johansson Michael Jackson and
many others none have gotten back to me
yet but I did get a green light from
A-list Hollywood actor Dax lame you
might know him from 21 Jump Street or
his YouTube channel we actually
collaborated to produce an AI cartoon
recently that combines meta's new
character animator along with
mid-journey and the voice cloning
technology that I'm going to show you
today I was given executive printer
credits on that project along with my
first Oscar nomination for printer of
the year you can watch the full short
film on his channel in any case there's
one big problem with my side hustle idea
I have no idea if anybody actually wants
to use it before you get two balls deep
into an idea it's a good idea to
validate the idea most of us don't want
to admit that we're delusional and our
ideas are actually garbage in this case
I have a YouTube channel to promote my
idea so in the next 24 hours I should
know if I have a billion dollar idea or
if I'm going to have to take this app
behind the barn and shoot it but here's
another thing you should know ideas are
cheap execution is everything by
execution I'm not talking about the
technology itself but rather the
business model because you could build
the most awesome app in the world but if
you don't have a good marketing plan
nobody's ever going to use it if you're
rich you can pay for advertisements or
pay influencers to chill for you but
assuming you're poor you'll likely have
to do some form of organic marketing
usually through social media like
Twitter Youtube Tick Tock or whatever
it's no different than fishing you want
to First figure out where the fish are
then put out some bait like an
advertisement or call to action then
once a user signs up you'll want to Club
them to death and then Grill them for
dinner and by that I mean provide them
with an awesome service that they'll be
happy to pay for now that you know not
to write any code until you have a
marketing plan let's talk about choosing
the optimal Tech stack it doesn't matter
if you use WordPress react or angular or
build some kind of freak Show on
kubernetes nobody cares except the tech
Bros on Twitter the only thing that
matters is that it works Peter levels
another Indie maker who earns at least
three million dollars a year from a
variety of different side hustles uses
boring old PHP and ignores all the
trendy developer products tech companies
try to sell you it's critical to find
technologies that optimize your
productivity and stick to them unless
you have a really good reason to move
somewhere else for me personally that
Tech stack is spelled kit and Firebase
also known as the it stack I also
use the carbon design system from IBM it
helped me get the UI belt very quickly
but in most of my projects I use
tailwind and build something a little
more custom from scratch ideally you
should have a great design to go along
with your app with a great landing page
that immediately explains why anyone
would want to pay for your product the
design should be functional beautiful
and unique in that order a great place
to find inspiration is mobbin.com which
curates designs from the top web and
mobile apps with any technology Choice
there are tons of trade-offs but I want
to highlight a few reasons why this Tech
stack in particular makes me feel so
productive on the front end most
developers choose react but the reason I
choose felt is pretty simple I just like
writing spelled code more so than react
one thing that's extremely demoralizing
is working with tools you don't like
it's not that I hate react or anything I
just like spelled more I even wrote my
own Library called smelt fire it
integrates spelled stores with Firebase
data in the code it allows me to read
data from my backend database by simply
putting a dollar sign in front of the
reference for that data this is quite
literally all the code it takes to get
an authenticated user then fetch the
data owned by that user that's pretty
cool but let's talk about Firebase you
have some pretty negative trade-offs
like vendor lock-in with Google cloud
and it can be expensive in certain
situations but here's how it simplifies
things in my application when a user
submits this form to get a voice clone
sample it will write this text to the
firestore database but on the back end a
lot of things need to happen first we
need to reach out to the 11 Labs API
which is the service that handles voice
cloning from there we have an audio file
that we need to save in a storage bucket
somewhere in the cloud we then need to
generate a secure download URL that
makes the file accessible only to that
one user then back in the front end we
need to show the user a loading State
and update the UI when the job is done
why the hell am I doing this when the
initial document is saved in firestore
it triggers a background function that
does all the work securely in the
background we don't need to expose any
HTTP endpoints to the front end what's
really awesome though is that the
Firebase SDK on the front end will keep
the database in sync in real time like
initially the document has a status of
processing then it goes to a status of
complete once we have a download URL in
the spell code this allows us to use an
if statement with the real-time store
that produces code that really can't get
any more simple when it comes to full
stack logic in addition we can secure
this code by ensuring that the
authenticated user only has access to
its own data with just a single line of
code in the security rules now the next
huge component of any application is the
database firestore is a document
database that's fast and easy to use but
is not always suitable for highly
complex data relationships in my case I
just have users and users can generate
many audio clips it's a very simple
relationship that's perfect for
firestore but choosing the wrong
database can be a disaster in general
relational databases like MySQL and
postgres are the safest bet for the
majority of applications but that
doesn't mean they're immune to their own
problems the YouTube channel code Dam
has a great eye-opening story about how
they hit the limitations of Limitless
scale with Prisma and Planet scale the
bottom line is to do your research and
be careful when choosing a database but
that brings us to our final top dollar
dollar bills y'all how do you actually
get that money unless you're some kind
of psychopath you'll want to use a
payments API and in my projects I've
always gone with stripe but there are
many other providers out there in my
application I give you 100 free tokens
to get started in my opinion it's always
a good idea to have some kind of free
trial to allow users to try out the app
in this case you can use my app for free
but once you run out of tokens you'll
need to buy more to handle that we have
an authenticated Firebase Cloud function
that generates a checkout session on
stripe which redirects the user to a
hosted checkout page so we don't have to
code up any of the UI manually now once
the user makes a payment stripe will
send a web hook to our server which
again is another Firebase Cloud function
the web hook will contain data about the
payment so we can look up the user in
Firebase and then update firestore with
the tokens they purchased in addition
I'm also using another service called
send Grid in this function you send a
transactional email to the customer with
their order confirmation but how much
should I be charging the customer for
these tokens well I'm going to use a
technique they teach in business school
called the versel strategy in my case 11
Labs charges 18 cents per 1000
characters generated with their voice
cloning service so what I'm going to do
is just jack up the price to 69 cents
per 1000 characters and that my friends
is how you build a money printing
machine if you want to go into more
detail I'm working on a new spell kit
Firebase course for pro members that
will teach you how to build an app just
like this it should be ready by the end
of June and here's a big discount on Pro
memberships if you want to be the first
to get access and that my friends is how
you Market a side hustle within a video
about side hustles thanks for watching
and I will see you in the next one